la coalición gobernante de polonia
perdió la mayoría en el parlamento uno
de los partidos de la alianza se retiró
tras una serie de desacuerdos con el
mayoritario ley y justicia sobre varias
reformas la más reciente es la ley de
medios de comunicación y es que la
controversial iniciativa fue aprobada
por un estrecho margen en el parlamento
polaco
228 votos a favor y 216 en contra ley y
justicia introdujo enmiendas para
prohibir a las empresas extranjeras
tener una participación mayoritaria en
la televisión la radio y la prensa
citando china y rúsia el gobierno alega
que es necesario para evitar la
posibilidad de que potencias extranjeras
tuve en el control de los medios polacos
pero los opositores consideran que es un
intento para obligar a la empresa
estadounidense discovery a vender tdn
una cadena de televisión crítica del
gobierno conservador soy el único fed
esta es una ley inconstitucional
diseñada para censurar a los medios de
comunicación libres y es inconsistente
con los tratados internacionales hoy
afecta a una de las estaciones de tv
pero de hecho afecta la seguridad de
polonia porque no es normal un inversor
ya no querrá invertir en un país donde
en una noche se pueda aprobar una ley
que de facto expulsa al capital de un
país aliado
la ley fue también criticada por estados
unidos
winfrey sabemos que unos medios de
comunicación libres e independientes
hacen que nuestra democracia sea más
fuerte por eso hemos instado al gobierno
de polonia a que demuestre sus
compromisos con estos principios que son
compartidos no sólo de palabras sino de
hecho a narón words and point y la
coalición polaca ha sido criticada por
la unión europea por algunas prácticas
que consideran hacen retroceder las
libertades democráticas